hey murdis can i talk to you privately
for a second about what your outfit
what
what's wrong with muffin
you you might consider pulling it down a
touch
that's right it's riding up a little
high
a bunch of prudes you know oscar's
allowed to wear sandals but i'm not open
to it
is that how it goes
meredith your boob is out fine
no no too far damn it meredith where are
your panties he's casual day
happy
no oh
hey meredith heading over to port
richards yep
cool cool cool
you need a ride
all right let's head out
sounds good you have a coat
yeah oh
okay
[Music]
oh so this is what every day would be
like if you hadn't left india
[Music]
burning oh
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
all right
well let's keep this party moving on
i'll go
have you guys ever met bruce myers the
scranton rep for hammer mill
well for the past six years i've been
sleeping with him in exchange for
discounts on our supplies and outback
steakhouse gift certificates
jackpot
meredith that is
serious
i mean not only is that a conflict of
interest but there's also an exchange of
goods
exchange of steak
have you ever had sirloin steak honey
that's crazy
that's crazy talk meredith
the marinator sleeping with suppliers
wow what time we got you know what
that's a good place to end it so
regarding this supplier
approximately how many liaisons have
there been liaisons you mean meetups
i don't know
once a month for six years something
like that meredith why don't you tell
holly it's not what she thinks
nothing unethical happened
and that you just like to sleep around
am i in trouble here or something new
no this is just a stupid formality
no it's not a formality
now were these um
meetups
just personal
unrelated to business nah i wouldn't
have done it if it wasn't for the
discount paper there's not a lot of
fruit in those wombs for the love of god
we're trying to help you you stupid bag
what i don't understand is
why the steak coupons
and if you were already getting the
discounted paper
well it's funny
maybe it's a girl thing but
after we did it
when he would give me those coupons
i just felt good about myself
thank you meredith this was delicious
hey where's the steak sauce
i think we're out i got some of my mini
band somewhere
wait a second
how does the steak factor in again i
think she got it as a tip
but i don't know why she didn't just
take cash i don't care what she's doing
i hope she just keeps doing it man just
keep the ribs coming
i would never do that waste of money
in my experience
guys are way more attracted to the back
of you than in the front
hey
there he is hey meredith how you feeling
i never thanked you for coming to the
hospital oh please it was my pleasure
while we all came so well i really
appreciate you coming i'm singling you
out
anyway i have this sharpie uh-huh and i
was wondering if you could sign my cast
um
can you write where i can read it oh
yeah
i'll read this when i go
all right
heard you guys need some pipes fixed or
cleaned or whatever angela special
repair man is here what what is this
shut up jakey
mom
wait wait what oh man no no no just do
your work pretend mom's not here uh that
seems inappropriate give him a good show
my little entrepreneur
okay take it off
[Music]
yeah good song choice shakey stripper's
only as good as a song wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh wow wow
[Applause]
okay
go meredith
okay if anything this is rougher stop it
meredith all right my bad
jake
[Music]
this is ridiculous why can't there just
be two kate middletons guys i know i
mean i wish there could be two it's like
i can't choose they're both amazing it's
just look i stayed up all night and i
watched that gd wedding and then i came
to work and made everyone else watch it
all day meredith wasn't even here
because i was there you are the people's
princess diana was nothing i thought you
were at your sister's funeral what i
said was my sister's funeral is this
weekend didn't say i'd be there why is
it such a shock that i followed the
royal story
warms my heart
thinking about them two kids
doing it
i don't mind telling you that i have an
addiction i do
to porn
oh
all right no no no no
that is
the image i think we can all agree is
very disgusting but
you know what meredith
you lit your hair on fire today what
about tomorrow what is going to happen
when you come into work
and you're dead
i stab her in the brain with a wooden
stick so what weapon
my bare hands that is stupid i will use
a sword and i will cut off your bare
hands then i'll get something too i've
had two men fight over me before
usually it's over which one gets to hold
the camcorder
hey boom guy
oh hey meredith when are you gonna boo
me uh listen they're cracking down on us
talking to the subjects it's a lame rule
but you know i wanna
i'll i'll see you later got it
you